cristiano ronaldo is the greatest player
the premier league has ever seen
are you going to tell me dennis burkham
no patrick vieira no
tony adams no it's here the only thank
you i was waiting for how long are you
going to call out
mary henry is the best player to play in
the premier league we're talking about
ronaldo done his best work in the league
[Music]
the man himself
a legend in your own making sure oh yeah
i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm good
the legendary andy tate in the building
man legend robert
united's travel winning team was better
than the invincibles
i'm still going to go invincibles
because it's never
ever been done right and it's not been
done since despite you know city
spending billions
chelsea spending billions they haven't
been able to do it you guys ain't been
able to do it and even despite that
great team that you had you weren't able
to do it either so but
drew 12 games 12. you know not you as
well you know well
you know you're not invincible don't get
me wrong that was it you know what this
thing why did you draw me in all the
league titles that you won why don't you
draw a load and become invincible you
know you'd love to have that we well
we're travel winners mate
we still why didn't you just we lost to
middlesbrough i went on in completely
unbeaten run to the end of the season
and we talked you out as well
if you can remember i was there at villa
park when vietnamese are you invincible
from middlesbrough to the end of the
season you remember that yeah but we got
three trophies but you want it you want
to diss us and talk about we got three
trophies
we made
some
only a few teams could do in the world
only a few only a few only one has been
invincible and i'll get fed up with this
thing about draws
right we won the league
it was in the back and now what we
wanted to do is just make sure that we
got over the line because wenger said it
from the start of the season we'll go
the whole season on invincible and
everybody laughed at him like your
manager always used to be laughing at
arsene wenger all the time he made
changes in the semi-final get [ __ ] out
then that cost y'all the fa cup as well
as the champions league you were going
for the treble last season you were
going to win everything and you it tap
you say you play your strongest side
over and over and over and you post a
new post and we posted a pie and we gave
everything and we got the rewards but
you made mistakes at games of the season
i ain't gonna lie used to annoy me that
arsene wenger didn't always go with the
strongest team because i think we would
have won more you know maybe fake cup
holders at the time yeah so that was
your fa cup you you consider that your
trophy i would consider it our trophy we
got a gold one mate gold gold gold gold
there's only one other thing in the
world a world cup you can't win that can
you that's the only other gold trophy in
the world yeah so we've got one of the
two
would you rather win the trouble
or be invincible
considering only a few teams over the
years
the great outside barcelona by munich
could only do it
invincible man stuff again
i've only lied
if i'm being honest
i'd rather won the treble because you
know that is unbelievable achievement
and we haven't won the champions league
and it still annoys me that we haven't
won a champions league especially when i
see chelsea winning it especially when i
see city you've nearly won it even a
couple of years ago tottenham nearly did
it you came so close we came so close so
that annoys me but
you know yeah if i'm being honest yet
the treble cristiano ronaldo is the
greatest player the premier league has
ever seen
come on andy you know it's not true
are you going to tell me dennis burkham
no patrick vieira no
tony adams no it's here the honorees
thank you i was waiting for how long are
you going to call that
marion is the best player to play in the
premier league we're talking
done his about
work in la liga for real madrid yeah he
he did well for you guys but then he
left thierry henry
best player for me ever
to play in the premier league now we're
in ronaldo
he's a great he won everything in six
years did act did see earlier win
everything no he didn't win everything
but again as i've referred back to as i
said today well yeah
yeah i want to go play championships all
day ronaldo i disagree with him say what
sienna is a great place i wanna
champions league with barcelona
he went to barcelona and he caught la
liga and uh i say he beat man united in
the final with pep 2009 so we're now
done we got one more champions league
trophy more than you ronaldo won ballon
d'or in that yeah um real madrid is
thierry henry won a ballon d'or he was
robbed he should have been ballon d'or
winner ronaldo won his first ballon d'or
at man united i didn't in his season i
thought i'd win a champions league as
well he done his best work at real
madrid do you know that he was a great
player we he was a great player he would
have won
that took a chance on him
you were the one who missed out on
ronaldo because arsene wenger even
looked at him in 2003 and it was it's
clearly he's clearly been stated
what of you you could have had you could
have had tearly henry and that uh and
ronaldo in this scene
don't remind me of that don't remind me
of that in the same squad such a legend
at your place he was about to go to man
city i was here
come on like i said come on
it was all part of the master plan i had
no master plan the day before
he signed for you guys
when it looked like he was going to see
what was you saying i know you oh i'll
be openly admitted i was really hurt
but what were you saying i said i've
heard a little well i'll say this now uh
coming here to this
nice arena
the gentleman in the taxi told me a
little story and it's his gods on his
truth this happened about an hour ago
the taxi driver told me he was holiday
in
monaco in the summer and uh basically
ronaldo was staying in a on the island
he was in a restaurant and he had a wag
with this gentleman and basically his
grandson went up to him got an autograph
and he said at the same time alex
ferguson was on the island at the same
time as ronaldo
so me and this was in june so maybe it
wasn't all
you know what i mean it was all hustlers
give me that
the gentleman in the taxi he was from
the east end west ham end west dam fan
don't believe western fans man trust me
and that hotel was probably owned by the
qataris
and he was set to come to manchester
mikhail arteta is a better manager than
holy gunner
social know where you're going where it
is
just because you've won an fa cup
trophies right trophies he won a trophy
i will go with olleh only because
he came in at a bad time
so
yeah the place was toxic it was absolute
desert after mourinho he steadied the
ship it took us on a 17 game unbeaten
run and it fell at the old days and he's
taken us to
third place
second place
a final
you've got brilliant players
pogba
ronaldo
mason greenwood rashford
maguire varane right throughout your
team de gea you've got a great side
already mikhail arteta came in and took
over he took a desert over as well
you're talking about you got to define a
europa league but that was only because
you finished third in your group in the
champions league right
remember that he got knocked out of the
champions league in the group stages
right this is obviously psg they would
be like sick and you got knocked out
knocked out have you seen champions
league football for a while i haven't
known oh well yeah
but you can die
no don't use that because you've got a
way better team and i'm saying that that
team should have got out of that group
he's got ronaldo at the moment he's
still flopping
he said steady the ship he's like that
you know that tanker they've got stuck
in the series canal yeah man yeah that's
that's the ship
yeah the blockage that's the ship
there's a blockage
at the wheeler
he's at the wheeler that way that's the
ship he's at the wheel yeah but our
right is just he's on a he's on a hiding
so nothing he's at well he's being
street he's getting used a lot of give
you give him an hard time one minute
like you go on a five game unbeaten run
you beat spurs last month oh yeah yeah
he's the best being six sliced bread no
we never said that you know you do two
all on monday with crystal palace and
you're celebrating like you won the fa
cup again would art setter do a better
job with that team at old trafford and
what would and what would dolly bring
to arsenal what would they get anywhere
all he gets really getting right the way
we've been playing um i think arteta
would do a better job
i do he'd have better players
could he manage eagles could he manage
ronaldo cavanagh pogba yeah i reckon he
could i reckon he could i i reckon he do
a bad job
remember he was at city and he had loads
of egos there
so i reckon he i reckon he'd do a better
job he can be a you can be a cracking
number two but you can't be sometimes a
number one i agree with that i agree
with that i'm just
purely judging it off of the fact that
if they both stopped being a manager
right now
mickey latter could say i want a trophy
wow wow one troll thing one troll female
continue it's about progression and
progression i'm gonna progression now
we're still knocking on the door whether
we get through the doors another thing
no one's opening it mate only one
person's
as long as your ollie is there well the
door will be permanent a lot for you for
the next five years we've found it
before you've opened it we've opened it
before but you will never get the
trinkets the more trinkets that fa cup
should lead to more
but you can't get them more can you well
i could see you could have got europa
league final b played or some basis yeah
you want to go into the champions league
and that was it yeah actually you
actually we blew it you blew it out
against theory we blew it we've broken
it
out really fast somebody else blew it
against villarreal as well yeah we did
we did
sorry right so i'm saying and that was
your pharma manager
true
so we stopped strung you up like a
kipper
[Laughter]
roy king was a better player than
patrick fierro
well we both set our targets so i'll go
first roy keane
he led by example he's won everything in
the in the game
and he spoke out even when he shunted
done
on his exit from manchester united and
he said what needed to be said even
though it caught out for many nights
it was chuck's outbox
he had to say what was needed to be said
because at the time we were
soft-centered well i'm going for era the
heroes are all-round footballer they
were both very similar in towards you
know they're both sort of like
players that were like
defensive midfielders stroke boxer box
midfielder and you know what there's not
really been any players since like him
you know i'd say as an all-around
footballer vieira was better and
wouldn't you say whoa
that's the anger
that's what they were always going at
each other as well and when you say
would you say right that roy keane's won
everything in the game he hasn't he
didn't win a world cup
vera is a world cup winner as well
so he's apart from the champions league
has won everything in the game but we
know right he's the best because why
would vieira bottle it twice
they've had things since they've done
that documentary roy keane said i
respected him because he was the one guy
that stood up to me he didn't back down
he didn't yeah down right you know yeah
right he's lucky he didn't stick it on
him he grabbed him by the throat
so he's grabbed him by the front and
then he grabbed him by the throat
right he's lucky well why did he bowl in
a in the tunnel but i didn't boat in the
tunnel where did he bowl in here the
whole side nervous
look at gary neville yeah he scored
didn't i
fell apart second afternoon really
helped me help me right
see you up on the pitch i see you on the
pitch
that's what he said
that noise noise right i mean i'm fair
to say that uh roy king didn't win the
wrong car he's an irishman
remember that not only did he not win
the world cup with ireland he ran out on
are you forgetting that he always spends
time with his dogs
mason greenwood will become a better
player
than saga
i'll go sucker i'll go sakura i i i
think sakura potentially will become
better and the reason why i say that is
that he's more focused than greenwood
you speak to anybody who knows him they
say that this kid is just like
dedicated to his football he's such a
nice kid
you know
focus
and there is no
you know you can see why gareth
southgate always picks him and trusts
him for england
greenwood on the other hand
was doing so well was progressing
then what did he do
and i'm not going to go in too hard on
him because he's a youngster he's a
young kid when i was that age i was
doing stupid things as well but even
foden and that's costing because
he should really be playing for england
now i feel and that's cost him and then
i also look on it and say to myself
at united is he going to get held back a
bit
because ronaldo's there because cavani's
there rashford so many
brilliant players
that are kind of in front of him they're
the senior guys this time will come but
they're kind of the senior guys now
and they're going to be the senior guys
for the next couple seasons right
we're a sucker he's one of the main guys
at arsenal he's like right now you're
you're the main guy we're relying on him
right so he's one of the main guys so i
think that will enable him to flourish
more
and to grow quicker the goals he scored
in his first season he always i've
watched him in the reserves with my dad
over the years this kid
he knows where the goal is that's great
in his first season like i say he scored
was it 14 goals he scored on his debut
and that was your old league but he's
got a is he can score his left foot
right foot he can take on players he's
going to get held back now that all of
those players that i just said are in
front of him i mean yeah you can learn
from a ronaldo but ronaldo starts and he
ain't gonna get in front of ronaldo is
he the kids was it 20. he's nick he's
20. you've got ronaldo 36 cavani 34-35
coming to the end of the careers he's
going to learn from two living legends
he could save us a packet
he could be on the same level as harland
mason and i think he's gonna do that
he's gonna save us at least he's gonna
be a 100 million pound player i would
say within the next three years it's two
great young players
i get upside down with my guy i'm
standing
the arsenal united rivalry of the early
2000's was the best the premier league
has seen
100 i missed those days i really missed
those days
that was you know you know what that
rivalry was like it was like we were
neighbors that was like a local derby
despite the fact that like you know
hundreds of miles apart
it was just a deadly rivalry
everything about it the two managers
were completely different
the styles of the team were different
you know roy keane and vieira
wenger fergie
you know fergie titan schmeichel against
david seaman and all right yeah
it was just
just everything about it
when those games came around
there's never been nothing like it since
but it's just a shame it's it's not
there i mean you've got american owners
like us and
they they care for nothing they don't
get it
they don't get they don't get engaged
you've got cranky we've got the glaciers
they don't understand i'm basically glad
that they tried to basically destroy
english football
last summer and they were all in denial
i mean you didn't want a babe you felt
left out i was i'll be honest i was
ready to walk away from supporting
united i would have watched him on the
telly but i would have stopped going we
actually agreed on some things
because we are agreeing you know in
those days i would never thought i'd
agree with anything on man united fancy
maybe the sound's going through the roof
as well isn't it possibly yeah yeah i
just think you guys are quiet that's
fair enough i mean you say we only sing
because there's nothing to sing about
you've got loads of things to sing about
you still don't so we do sing i gotta
told you it's just i tell you what
because of the song guys are really loud
outside the stage
of the country that's the issue so
you're really loud outside the stage
with the protesters up there